Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Oh, here. Oh, sorry.
And then we're going to
just read you the instructions here.
I wish there had been another book.
Okay, cool.
When you're ready, you can press pace.
Okay.
You can pause and play.
Is there anywhere I should just talk?
Yeah, just the screen.
Okay.
Good, strong movements.
Could be a little bit longer stances,
but if we're not doing Poomsae in a while,
it's pretty good.
Strong punches.
Again, stance could be longer,
but still pretty good.
Oh, I felt good here at the key-up.
Thought that was powerful.
Overall, execution, I think, was good.
Did the movements, even though it's low blocks and punches,
pretty basic, so
I didn't feel too nervous about
a kick or a jump, but overall,
I think it was strong.
With some minor changes, that could be done with technique,
but overall, pretty decent.